our first story from our good friends
over at Media Matters who I thought you
know it's the perfect website to use
when talking about the big con and
Stephen Crowder
mediamatters.org says Stephen Crowder
lashes out at big con of conservative
media for allegedly colluding with tech
companies like YouTube quote those in
charge the big conservative the big con
and it really is the biggest con going
right now they're making it known in
their contracts that they will enforce
the guidelines of big Tech and punish
conservatives on their behalf
Stephen Crowder one of the most
prominent if not the most prominent
prominent I guess what would you
describe this conservative media
movement or or anti-establishment
movement one of the most prominent
voices if not the most prominent put out
a video today
just straight up calling out big
conservative media and I commented on
the video I said he's right about
everything but I want to clarify what I
mean by that because maybe maybe it's a
little inappropriate he's right about
the contracts he's right about the
machine he's right about how this whole
system works but there's an
understanding you need to have the
machine itself is the these contracts
it's the product of
how the law is structured how the market
is structured and it's an inevitability
the only way it changes when people like
Stephen Crowder don't sign these deals
people like any of you who are signing
up don't sign these deals
say no to these deals and build a
completely new system and that means
we've got big challenges it means that
Disney's got an advantage you want to
know why Disney's got an advantage
because when when Stephen Crowder
he leaves The Blaze
he's obviously shopping around that's
why he's got this contract he says these
terms are insane
he doesn't need to sign it many people
do need to sign these deals and they do
sign these deals for a company like
Disney I remember I got a contract from
them I signed it it was a lot of cash a
lot of cash I didn't have and I said
okay
and then within the confines of that
contract I eventually was like I know
what I have to do and I know what I'm
not going to do and you're not going to
get me to do anything please break my
contract they said no I got locked up
for a couple years they call that golden
handcuffs it is extremely common in the
media industry
I think Jack euger talked about it when
he was at MSNBC yep same thing happened
to Jesse Ventura when he was critical of
the war in Iraq they silenced him and
essentially got rid of his show that
they paid a lot of money for and he
essentially a year was just sitting and
couldn't do any interviews or his own
show which is absolutely so let's let's
do this I'll I'll start off by saying um
Stephen Crowder launching his own thing
is the most important thing he can do
but that the the current reality of big
media especially with an
anti-establishment landscape is that
these deals are quite literally
impossible and more importantly
they're impossible for someone like
Stephen Crowder
so I'll say this to get started and then
you're gonna have to ask me questions I
guess on what you're thinking Crowder's
too big there's no way anyone can sign a
deal with Stephen Crowder uh it's just
that simple dude's got nearly 6 million
subscribers how do you do a deal with
this man he owns the space so imagine
you're we've got a handful of companies
uh obviously everybody's giving their
thoughts on which company they think
this wasn't offered them a contract but
there's a lot right obviously there was
the blaze I know we know rumble's doing
it a lot of deals with people the daily
wires obviously another big one they've
got a big roster what are some other
companies in in the space are there any
beautiful Wars Infowars obviously I
doubt I doubt Infowars uh I don't know
if Stephen will go to Infowars though
Ohan no no I mean Newsmax uh given the
legal troubles crowd probably not
honestly fox fox is there yeah
absolutely Fox they're looking for a
comedian to host I heard well well
they got Gutfeld he's he's slain it yeah
Alex Jones and Steve and Stephen Crowder
did multiple interviews and Alex Jones
even said that he's moving away from his
kind of libertarian policies and
agreeing with Stephen when it comes to
more kind of status Solutions it's
possible it's completely possible so
everybody has their speculation crtv is
also another big one crtv is the blaze
oh God yeah and and turning points are
maybe but I think Fox is probably a
really good guest too like people got it
people gotta understand
whoever this company is like I would
tell you fox probably has the worst
terms you guys want to play some games
Fox guests aren't allowed on this show
actually
I don't know about contractually I just
know that probably pissing off Fox right
now yeah like we we routinely have
people say stuff like I wish I'm a big
fan we love the show we'd love to come
on too bad we can't by the way Fox
whoever you guys have your people come
on because it would be phenomenal for
all of us is it this show specifically
or just any podcast form this show is
specifically blacklisted for Fox
personalities
um that doesn't make any sense to me oh
that makes absolute sense we compete
directly with Tucker Carlson yeah a lot
of people see a competition instead of
actually you know working together
cohesively there's also uh prageru epac
times there's a lot of media
organizations in the space that do have
the money that could facilitate this who
but but how do you do a deal with
Stephen Curry because let's break it
down let's let's break it down you got
six million subscribers on Stephen
Crowder's Channel let's say you create
the Crowder Club you know he's got a mug
Club but let's say you're um I don't
want to name any company so let's make
up a fake one uh conservative Inc let's
say you run conservative Inc and you're
like we got some investor cash you know
bigwig libertarian billionaire who
bought a bunch of Bitcoin because the
creep can afford to invest he's helping
run our company investing in our company
we can hire one of these guys how much
can we reasonably afford to spend let's
think about the revenues uh we'll use
the daily wire because they've talked
about their numbers what do they have
900 000 paying subscribers yeah is that
what it was yeah Matt Walsh really
brought in that money for them to be to
be honest so let's just look at their
their memberships they got a seven
dollar a 10 or 13 or something like that
so let's just go for the middle and say
it's like ten dollars per person they're
doing what nine million dollars in
membership Revenue per month they've
also got what seven big personalities
they've also got ad Revenue
let me let me let me do a quick math on
what I pre what I think their ad Revenue
might be well actually no I think they
said well didn't it say they were doing
like 100 million a year or something
like that I don't remember I don't
remember either it was like 120. I'd be
willing to bet that uh they probably do
I don't know 15 is a rent it's a guess
15 million bucks per month sponsorship
Revenue only goes so far you can be
really really big but it only goes so
far so let's say it's the bulk as
memberships 15 million per month but you
got to pay for what do they have 300
employees
I don't know the numbers of daily wire
very well let's say top level Talent has
to be extraordinarily expensive Jordan
Peterson I mean oh yeah Jordan Peterson
I imagine they'd pay him like I was
going to mention that like 10 million
bucks in comparison to Stephen Crowder
where is where does Jordan Peterson fall
there Jordan Peterson's a very different
personality Stephen Crowder has
guaranteed numbers right when you when
when you when you're trying to sign
someone like Crowder you're like I can
look at how many people comment I can
look at how many people view each of
your videos and not only that
if he's got
um uh membership only content he can
provide those metrics as well and then
you can say I know how much money I can
make off this
but imagine you're uh you know I don't
even know how much money fox makes they
have like they have like cable contracts
which guarantees them probably like
you know hundreds of millions of dollars
per year yeah guaranteed just for being
on the cable networks because the cable
deals they're they that people sign up
for cable because they want Fox News
right
so Fox News how much my question is this
let's say conservative Inc contacts
Stephen Crowder how much can they
reasonably afford to pay him how much
they can how much can they make off of
him and how do they make money off of
him let's take a look at this contract
in this video you can see this it says
merch rights blank will maintain the
exclusive right to create and sell
Crowder and Crowder content branded
merchandise all remuneration for the
blank and exploitation of these rights
is included in the fee
okay email list blank will maintain the
exclusive rights to manage grow and
monetize all crowd or email email lists
during the term all remuneration for the
exploitation of these rights is included
in the fee
social media management blank will have
the exclusive right to manage curate and
monetize Crowder's official Facebook
YouTube Apple podcast Spotify Snapchat
Rumble and other social media accounts
excluding Crowder's existing personal
Twitter and Instagram accounts during
the term additionally blank will have
the perpetual and exclusive right to
create own managed curate and monetize
any and all social media accounts on any
social media or similar platform as
determined by blank on the Crowder
content or shows all remuneration for
the exploitation of these rights is
included in the fee what's the fee
well Crowder offered 100 million dollars
because I got to tell you if someone
came to me and said look
we can make merch based on you ours we
can manage an email list everything
hours
we're going to handle all of our social
media content all of that will happen
only within the term as it states in the
contract what's the term typically three
years is what they'll try to get you on
whenever I was negotiating contracts
they'd always say three years and I'd
laugh and I'd say no and they but that's
standard I'm like I don't care what
standard we'll do two years and two
years is kind of I did two years of
fusion what's the fee
is Crowder mad that they offered him a
really garbage fee in exchange for
control of all of his all of his rights
and all of his production it's possible
I don't know don't know how much money
he was offered but I'll tell you this if
he was offered say 200 million dollars
over three years is that contract
unreasonable no if he was offered five
million dollars for three years then
it's unreasonable absolutely yeah so
that's a big question here this contract
may look exploitative but it's really we
don't know the consideration exactly if
I went to you and said
I will give you like if if I had a
contract and it said like you must turn
over your house immediately
you must give me all property you own
and then you went around showing people
like look at this contract it says he
can take everything from me people might
be like wow that's crazy and then he's
not showing you the page where it says
in exchange I give you my house and a
million dollars you know what I mean
it's like we don't know if the deal is
fair or not if you're gonna sell your
soul you better back up the Brinks truck
you know like it better be better be
heavy money because as you said Crowder
is making crazy money so he doesn't need
to sell his easy though well do you not
think so with Mud Club and all that who
owns my club he said he owns it he owns
it yeah he owns it now or he owned it
before I don't know in this video from
from what I saw I watched about 20
minutes of it he was saying that
basically we can do this on our own with
mug Club I can open up my own thing if I
if need be but he didn't really go into
specifics about how much he's making so
if he's going to open up his own thing
I'll tell you man
Crowder with 6 million subscribers when
he did the the coverage of the midterms
and he had what like half a million live
viewers
if I was gonna just spitball a number
that I think Crowder independent would
make it would be 10 million per month
wow the daily wire is Big the daily wire
is basically Ben Shapiro you've got Ben
Shapiro and then you go down the the
roster so it's like Matt Walsh now maybe
their biggest money maker
oh yeah what is a woman was was just
massive these are things they've stated
publicly right they've talked about how
they brought in like 300 000 new members
off that alone I think that's what they
said I don't know for sure it's just
what what I heard and I mean you got to
think about that 300 000 new members on
a documentary that probably cost a
couple hundred grand to make a couple
hundred grand a market if you want to do
it big true they had a Times Square
billboard I think they I think that
running yeah they knocked it out of the
park with that so imagine you got 13
bucks a month is the tier to watch video
and you had 300 000 people
let's say the average person stays on as
a member the churn rate for every
company is different but let's say it's
a year
that's a lot of money to come in off one
documentary I need to ask you a question
because you've got a lot of more
experience with YouTube by the way twice
struck liberty lockdown please forgive
me my overlords I'm sorry I know not
what I've done
um but that's no joke your channel got
two strikes in the last what three weeks
ten days since I had James Lindsay on uh
he went down the same line of thinking
that he expressed on this fine program I
have no idea what I did wrong and they
will not tell me they won't give me a
timestamp it just it breaks my heart I'm
trying my best to stay on there I really
it's important that you guys are
listening to admins because Clint is you
actually mentioned you might not even be
putting videos on YouTube for like 90
days out of fear that you get a third
strike for unknown reasons I can't risk
it and that's not good so if you guys
can look at that and please I'm begging
um but the reason I wanted to ask Tim is
because he's got so much experience with
this are are you basically saying that
Google
because of the parent company of YouTube
is is so well ran in terms of paying
their their creators that you cannot
really compete in this space any any
longer what do you mean well it seems as
if you're you're implying that because
Crowder has such an enormous following
on YouTube and the revenue that he's
deriving from that okay go ahead no no
what I'm saying is that
the people who run let's let's let's
just let's just I don't want to name any
specific companies I don't call anybody
out sure
um a lot of people are like name names
name names I don't think there's bad
guys here if you're a businessman and
you're like how do we cultivate Talent
so look at the daily y for example
Michael Knowles Rose from inside the
daily wire what was he like he's an
editor or something I can't remember
what his job was yeah he was behind the
scenes they found Talent they cultivated
that talent and they found a rising star
so so before the show we were getting
into it and I was like we got to save it
for the show let me tell you something
we make a lot of money uh at timcast.com
I've never talked about our next our
membership numbers things like that
because
I don't know it's a private business
we're not a non-profit you know uh and I
don't I don't I think a lot of people
don't understand how expensive things
can be and money
um when it comes to you know doing
things like this but we do make a lot
and I love that you rake by the way we
do we do I love it I I I think we do
around uh eight figures per year that's
beautiful so this and it's almost
exclusively just me personally
so we have employees who help run Tim
cast IRL where's the Bugatti yet where's
the private where's the private I have a
Model S the Bugatti's right here baby
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time